Piers Morgan did ask Ron DeSantis about
allegations
that he backed the force-feeding of
prisoners while serving at Guantanamo
Bay DeSantis says it's not true but he
gets a little mushy-mouthed about it one
of the things I said was that you
authorized the use of force-feeding
that's some of the yeah that's not true
yeah any of the stuff that people must
have finished it Force feeding the
detainees who were on Hunger Strike was
that true so I was a I was a junior
officer I didn't have authority to
authorize anything there may have been a
commander that would have done feeding
if someone was going to die but that was
not something that I would have even had
authority to do so that's that's wrong
yeah yeah absolutely okay uh and by the
way DeSantis is saying it's it's a raw
it's wrong to claim he did it not that
it's wrong to do the force feeding